a judge is expected to sentence Bill
Cosby today for drugging and sexually
assaulting a woman at his home in
Pennsylvania Cosby faces up to 10 years
in prison after his three assault
convictions were merged into one in
court yesterday more than 60 women
accused him of sexual misconduct tarika
Duncan spoke with the juror who voted to
convict Cosby and she's outside the
Montgomery County Courthouse in
Norristown Pennsylvania tricot good
morning good morning to you day one of
Cosby's sentencing hearing Monday lasted
about five hours and at the heart of
this case andrea constand she testified
and not only did she testify but her
mother did her bother and her older
sister and even some of Cosby's accusers
were here the man once known as
America's dad made his way into court
yesterday as protesters shouted in
support of his accusers andrea constand
who cosby was convicted in April of
drugging and molesting at his home in
2004 took the stand const and read a
small portion of her victim impact
statement telling the court all i am
asking for is justice as the court sees
fit later district attorney Kevin Steele
read other parts of constan statement
and which constan describes feeling like
a knife was in her gut whenever she
heard Cosby's voice constants family
testified about her change in demeanor
after her encounter with Cosby her mom
told the court I don't believe in my
heart Bill Cosby has ever cared constant
sister called her a hero prosecutors
asked for the maximum prison sentence of
five to ten years based on the nature of
the crime and his alleged history of
misconduct the defense expressed concern
about Cosby's health and safety if the
81 year old legally blind man goes to
prison they asked for house arrest
instead attorney Gloria Allred who
represents a number of Cosby accusers
spoke after the hearing they feel that
what was done to them
was sexually violent and that the person
who did it to them is a sexually violent
predator some of those accusers were
inside the courtroom yesterday so were
four of the trials jurors including
Diane celsa although we have no part in
sentencing we just want to see it come
to conclusion mostly for the victims
particularly for andrea constand what
were you expecting coming into the
sentencing hearing my hope is that bill
cosby will be sentenced appropriately we
as a jury convicted him and I hope that
he is going to be held accountable
yesterday a state psychologist testified
that Cosby shows signs of suffering from
a mental disorder that involves urges
uncontrollable urges when it comes to
violating helpless women now today a
psychologist for the defense is expected
to take the stand it is after that that
the judge will will will rule whether or
not to designate Bill Cosby as a
sexually violent predator and then he
will deliver his sentence Gayle boy will
be watching thank you very much tariqa